when i first like really dug into this  mission of being the first it i'll be  honest with you it was like my  competitive spirit my  internal individual personal drive  but it was not it wasn't very long at  all  after i kind of like set out on this  mission that i realized it was about way  way more than that and i know that  sounds like super cheesy  but  i've had dads message me they're like  you know i was watching the ufc and you  came on television and my daughter  walked in the room was like who's this  and he said and it literally  opened up an opportunity for me to have  a conversation with her about like  you know  you can you can enter these arenas where  it's a male-dominated situation and you  can still have a place yep if you do it  right yep and i'm not the skills i'm you  have to have the skills that's number  one  of course it is